Speaker 1: Hey, I don't want to spend a lot of
time on this, but I do want to mention it. One
of the things that Trump's former lawyer, Michael
Cohen, has said Trump did and that we know Trump
did is the same asset. If he wants to avoid taxes,
he says it's not worth a lot. And if he wants to
get a loan against it or be, you know, richer on
the Forbes list, he'll say it's worth more. We now
have a specific example, and it's all related
to a Trump golf club. The AP reporting Trump
Golf Club reportedly faces new criminal probe
over taxes. Westchester Club allegedly misled
officials to reduce taxes. And fundamentally,
what Donald Trump did here is the same golf club,
he said. In one place, this thing's worth
more than $50 million. And elsewhere, he said,
it's only worth $1.4 million. Rachel Maddow
explains it really well. Let's take a look
Speaker 2: at the numbers here are easy to keep
in your head. The town is selling to pay taxes
on a golf course that they say is worth $15
million. He's saying No, no, I won't. It's only
worth one point four million dollars, right? But
that same year, in twenty sixteen, he files his
financial disclosure statement as a presidential
candidate. He files it in May 2016, United States
Office of Government Ethics Executive Branch
Personnel Public Financial Disclosure Report.
The town said the golf course again was worth 15
million. He said, No, I'm not saying paying taxes
on a $15 million property that's only worth
one point four million. But look at what he
put in his official financial disclosure that
same year. His official financial disclosure
line item ninety three Trump National Golf Club
Westchester County value over 50 million dollars.
So the one part of the government, he's telling
them this golf course is worth over $50 million.
But for the tax authorities, he's saying
it's $1.4 million dollars, right? How can
something simultaneously be worth over
$50 million if you're talking to Trump
and only one point four million? Also, according
to Trump? How can that be true at the same time?
Speaker 1: So this is this is actually it's
really actually quite simple. This is exactly
what Michael Cohen described. This is exactly
what has been otherwise reported that Trump does
if he needs to pump up his net worth or he needs
to borrow money. He goes, Look at this beautiful
asset. Look at this perfect golf course worth $50
million. Loan me twenty five million because I've
got this $50 million asset, I can can prop up
as collateral for it. OK? On the other hand,
if it's hey, you've got to pay taxes, you've got
to pay taxes on this 50 million or, as the town
believed, it was $15 million asset. Trump goes on,
I don't have any money. First of all, this is only
worth $1.4 million, so the taxes should be levied
on that amount. And I don't even have the money
to pay taxes as if it were worth $15 million.
This is similar to keeping two sets of books.
It's not the same. It's similar to keeping two
sets of books, which is not allowed. And this
is now part of this new probe. So no big shock.
Just another data point that this was a technique
that Donald Trump used. We knew it already. But
that's another data point of Trump's usage of it.